trash taste baby trash taste trash test
trash test are we rolling or what oh
I'm just gonna say like I saw the red
lights on I was like oh
hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast I'm
Joey and I'm with Garten Connor as you
hold on I haven't had my morning I've
had my morning
old man needs his old man stretches it
is it is man it is gone to this 4am walk
it's all old men do dude I must say like
I started getting into the habit of just
getting up and doing like two minute
stretches like once the moment I wake up
yeah op as hell how's your circulation
bro how's your circulation I can feel
the blood just like trickling through my
legs I'm just like because like I always
had that problem do you guys have that
problem when you wake up and you just
like
stiff as a brick yeah I don't I don't
mean the other way
this is another episode of uh we are
becoming old rapidly
no no because I never had that you know
like [__] three four years ago right
I just [__] wake up and be like all
right I'm good to go but nowadays I wake
up and I can I can feel like the cogs
just
sometimes you can feel a bit stiff after
you wake up in the morning I don't know
you don't want like a dick well that as
well
I'm not doing anything with that morning
I'm not stretching that in the morning
honey I'm not jacking off I'm having my
morning stress yeah I'm just saying I
just want to make sure it's the same
page
no but like I've just gone to the habit
now because like now that I am
approaching 30 and I know how you feel
now gone because it's like my body is
just not functioning in the morning
anymore
stopped exercising
I've always been like super like not
flexible yeah like for the longest time
like I still can't touch my toes or
anything like that I am rock hard pause
okay now he's doing it
for us you know getting up in the
morning and just doing like like what
you were just doing and just two minute
stretches and it's like oh this is why
people do stretches in the morning now
it actually because I always thought it
was like a placebo thing yeah you know
because it's like hundreds of old people
just like it's a placebo you're
definitely just get up have your coffee
you'll be good to go tell me that
ringfit lied to me
what the [__] dude I always skip that
[__]
come on oh yeah no she's now alone I'm
now feeling the consequences I just
understand now you're paying back like
20 something years of not stretching
yeah before exercising pretty much oh my
God and now it's finally caught up to me
and I'm like oh maybe I should maybe the
stretches in the morning actually mean
something
yeah maybe the doctor's advice was
actually uh was actually useful and the
the doctor had a point and uh yeah it
was just like talking [__] yeah
but yeah how have you guys been in the
past few days Connor you've been uh
taking care of your parents right I have
yeah it's first time right yeah yeah
that's what that first time in Japan
well everyone I'm Connor's Dad
why are you talking like you're in a
conference I don't know family's coming
in I'm showing Ned though hi everybody
we're in Japan at the moment visiting
Connor hi
every time anything happened I was like
I'll tell that on the podcast and
they're all like
don't don't say that
why have there been like already I mean
it's just like you know my my parents
because like I think a lot of people who
travel to Japan especially our age like
they like are already kind of into Japan
and already have like researched a bunch
yeah
um they don't get normally like just
dragged here and even like people who
like want to visit here will normally
like look up stuff to do or we'll look
up something and and so my parents kind
of like even though they are interested
in Japan and they they were really
really excited for the trip like they
didn't like research they weren't like
oh my God what's on San educator oh my
God how should I well they don't have to
because yeah yeah yeah
and like I realized oh my God I have to
like I have to explain everything right
whereas like sometimes when friends come
over it's like okay I don't have to
explain everything and they can get
around well like they didn't know
anything yeah most people who visited
kind of have their own motives already
right yeah they figured stuff out and
they they maybe planned the trains and
stuff but you know I think everything
kind of sounded overwhelming when I like
told them I was like okay I'll just
figure it out so like I booked them uh a
taxi from Narita to to take them to the
hotel which is like two hours right
expensive taxes for me yeah yeah I'm
paying it why didn't you just throw them
on the narrator Express oh because I was
like man they're gonna they're gonna be
overwhelmed absolutely first time in
Asia of having to figure it out like
also the first time in Asia yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah and I think there's still
that like and I realize that everyone
has this where you're like I don't know
it's like English will be okay right
like and it's like yeah no it won't be
okay maybe on the Naruto Express yeah
okay but like it's like I'm sure like
this is not me being like all right it's
not about I do I think they could figure
it out yeah they could figure it out but
yeah it's like all right do I really
want to put that stress on them right
right away it's like okay I could just
get them a cab and I'll front the cost
and then all they have to do is just
look for the guy with the name and then
apparently that somehow that [__] up
too because it was like 4am because we
were in Hawaii yeah and I was like you
know I was making sure that when they
landed I was like hey did you get in the
cab okay is it all good and they're like
yeah it's all good it's all good
and I I want I was going to go to sleep
when I knew they got to the hotel and
they could find like you know rest and
then I I wouldn't have to worry then
about you know because I booked the
hotel I booked everything everything is
all booked by me and I was like I just
didn't want like a [__] up where maybe I
put the name wrong or something you know
what kind of did actually [__] up
because I I remember uh I remember
because uh his parents it's not it's not
just his parents that have come along
but we have a friend from England who's
flowing all the way here that I think
landed on the same day as your parents
two days after two days after all right
but like I remember thinking uh so I
remember Conor was like mentioning oh
yeah I'm gonna come back from Hawaii
then pick my parents up and I was like
wait a minute I was checking the dates
because I was having to make sure the
dates of when our friend lands as well I
was like wait a minute Connor mentioned
his parents come back on this day yeah
but we fly back on from Hawaii the day
after that was the one thing I did
annoying I'm like does Connor realize
this or I did realize that and I told my
parents that but then I didn't tell my
friend that so yeah it's kind of like a
miscommunication because there's so many
things
and then myself which is already I'm Not
Gonna Keep in track of this yeah yeah so
so I you know I got them a taxi and I'm
in the Hawaii hotel room and then
they're like oh we think the taxi driver
is going the wrong way I'm like I don't
think the taxi driver would go the wrong
way I gave him the address how would
your parents know I don't know because
they're just freaking out right they
just haven't been to it and everything's
new and the tax driver doesn't speak any
English because of course I don't speak
English uh and so they call me up and
they're like I think the taxi director
told me well shouldn't my mum calls me
while she's like I I don't think they
know where to go yeah I replied in
English I was like Mom I don't think
they can speak English I don't think you
need to speak to me in Welsh
um your mom's trying to be like the
screen
yeah you don't need to worry about it
and even if they did speak English they
wouldn't understand like British English
yeah yeah you did yeah um so they hand
me the phone I'm like okay fine okay
they're like yeah we think the taxi
driver is going the wrong way I'm like I
don't I think it's fine so they hand the
phone to the taxi driver and the taxi
driver is like sounds like a young woman
and she just sounded like terrified that
I think my parents just shoved the phone
to her and then some weird guys talking
in Japanese to her and so I was like
hazel Ransom calling I was like hey uh
my parents are just kind of nervous
um do you have the address and she just
sounded like utterly panicked by that
question and I was like all right then
she was like oh she's like freaking out
you can imagine how it is yeah it
sounded very flushed and very panicked
and I was like all right then and I know
I was like I'll just hand it back she
handed it back and I was like yeah she
knows where she's going I didn't know I
was like I was like
meanwhile everyone in that cab is
sweating yeah I'm like don't worry about
it I'm sure she knows and of course she
knew where she was going yeah yeah um
and I was like this is so so stupid but
then you know and then I think it
proceeded to be like all right let's
every little thing where I'm not there
they would like worry about it and then
like double check with me and so the um
the first day we had to do we have to
record trash station no I had to do
something I had to do a live stream yeah
and so I was like hey just go here for
lunch walk around and so they're walking
around and they're texting me stuff and
they're like oh we found like a a cafe
to drink and they sent me a picture and
my God it looks like the shittiest Cafe
in all of Japan it's like it's like yeah
it has an outside Terrace and it's
let me show you a picture okay it's like
unfair to even call this a Terrace do
they not just think to like walk into
like a Starbucks I think I think they
didn't want to go to Starbucks and also
I think they were also like look at this
oh
that doesn't even look like a cafe and
this is something that I've learned and
I know this because I had the same thing
myself I said like it is super
intimidating in Japan for people who've
never gone to Japan or Asia in general
to to to imagine having to go into a
building without being able to see it
immediately what's inside yes yeah so I
think for them my parents it was like
okay well Terrace equals I can kind of
see what's going on and then there's
also hundreds of miscommunications they
keep telling me about where they're like
my mom is obsessed with cider as right a
British woman yeah wants to drink siding
alcohol excited yeah which just doesn't
exist in Japan no no and in America it's
called hard cider but here it's like
what do they call it Cedar but then
there's also normal cider which is
yeah you can imagine
but even this is just assuming because
she's like oh do you have silent like
yes we have cider and they bring up
and so this has been a constant
frustration right now where I'm always
just like every single place we go to
I'm she's like do they have side I'm
like Mom they don't have cider I'll tell
you when they have cider mum which is
never because they won't ever have it
yeah like ironically enough the only
place in Japan that has cider are
British pubs yeah exactly yeah that you
you probably uh find more chance of
getting a Cider at a hub
oh my God imagining your parents in a
hole yeah it's really nice
but I mean I mean I I get it right
because I remember when I first moved to
Japan right there's there's a big
barrier you have to get past in terms of
like just going into a restaurant and
committing to opening the door yeah oh
right so it's terrifying yeah yeah
because once you commit now like you
still do it but yeah there's that
millisecond I mean I hated it and I
could speak the language yeah yeah
because you're like once you open a door
you're like [__] I've committed to like
sitting down at this yeah I don't want
to be the [__] that immediately turns
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've had to become because you know I
was at some point I've been sharing my
friend come with my parents around at
the same time right yeah and it means
that like and they all love drinking so
I've had to become the vibe Checker
which I mean I have to you just have to
walk into a you know a narrow building
on like the fifth floor of some really
sketchy looking thing and I have to pop
my head and be like oh no no sorry yeah
go out and it's really awkward but and
like my dad as well he's um he loves
beer and every single time when we get
we get a beer he's like what beer is it
I'm like
I don't know I haven't I've never
questioned it in three years it just
always comes out tasting Goods so I just
I've noticed every time he asks me I was
like I just don't know just drink it
it's me it's fine like I every single
time he likes the beer
it's just like it's it's very fun taking
them around but after like like multiple
days of this I've been getting this same
question I'm like I'm gonna lose
my mind being asked these questions over
and over again but it's been fun they
love the bullet trains everyone seems to
love bullet trains as well every foreign
person I think people from outside Japan
just like find that concept so insane
yeah because it's like well like I think
like China is the only other country
that has trains that go that fast yeah I
think I think no Europe has high speed
rails does it yeah I don't think it's as
well connected nearly as well connected
yeah or run on time or because I think
like a million people a day use the
shinkansen which is like insane amounts
of well I think it's all just also just
like I wouldn't say like the marketing
but like the prestige because it was
actually like one of the first and one
of the most famous right it was the
Japanese bullet train yeah like this is
when this is when like Japan was in the
Heights or when you think Japan you
think the bullet train yeah this is when
Japan was like the height of the center
of Technology sure you know yeah they
loved it yeah and that that image is
just like state because even my parents
right I was I asked my mom and dad when
they come to Japan what do you want to
do my dad's like take me in the bullet
train I was like that's uh out of where
out of everything that's what you want
to do okay Dad okay he's just like I'm
excited for the bullet train yeah yeah I
mean it's fun it's not about the
destination it's about the journey yeah
yeah exactly that is the destination the
bullet train is great seeing at the when
the train leaves at 9 57 I can tell them
look at the clock when it turns to 957
the trains oh that's my favorite thing I
might not watch watch yeah it's gonna
come ride like literally the doors oh
close and go 1987 I'm like that's sick
that's awesome
um I mean they love that my dad is
fascinated by it he loved all that they
I mean they like it so far like in uh
most of the food they like I've made
them try pretty much everything yeah and
are they like generally okay with like
food like is the food palette wide or I
thought it was like non-existent right I
thought they weren't going to eat
anything right but then they've eaten
everything
we're gonna have dinner and uh yeah
there's one place I only serve like raw
meat yeah it was it was basically a a
place that specialized in raw meats and
fish uh and we realized that after
sitting down and like half the menu was
just like raw horse meat raw beef oh
yeah baby shrimp and every every kind of
raw meats yeah this is a little baby
looking squid thing that's common in
spring in Japan and uh that was the
appetizer that came out and it just
looks like oh yeah
yeah shrunken down yeah yeah that was
like the first thing my parents had it
was kind of different
um they were like I was like try it like
Dark Souls yeah those are their credit
they they ate one of them they didn't no
they they tried at least they tried it I
was impressed I thought no shots
eat it and swallow it they didn't spit a
single thing out oh that's good I took
them to a sushiro as well because I was
like I was like because I'm gonna take
them to a nice the finest job yeah so so
my thing was I wanted them to try
dirt cheap sushi and so you know like
this is what it should taste like yeah
like this is like compared to the UK
have you ever had UK Sushi before yeah
they have they have did they like it I
think they liked it yeah but I mean
again they'll never eat it again yes
yeah and like it was very westernized
but I couldn't you know I mean I when I
go to sushi or something I don't try
anything [__] crazy stuff I just get
the standard oh no no no no I'll get
like I'm not having the [__]
hamburger Sushi [__] that [__] yeah yeah
and so like you know they were like yeah
it's nice yeah I don't think they like
loved it yeah they pretty much enjoyed
it but they recognized that it's like
even the yeah the minimum here is better
than anything again kept saying uh oh
it's not it doesn't smell fishy I'm like
yeah yeah I think so yeah yeah
um and then uh tempura they liked you
went to a really nice Temple oh hell
yeah yeah foreigners loved him I mean
it's just fried food isn't it like yeah
what's not to like about fried fruit
well I I mean I gave so this is uh
tempura restaurant in uh called
um oh [__] it's called tempura
and or something uh Chris took me to it
because it was like it's almost Chris
way of tell yeah yeah it's really famous
in Kyoto and Christian Chris the way
Chris sold me on it because it was like
it's like 200 of course damn it's crazy
Chris is like no no it's Steve Jobs's
favorite restaurant
I think it's really good to be fair they
give you like 15 pieces of tempura and
stuff and they loved all of it you know
I I because they give you like like
shrimp head as well where all the tail
and stuff yeah and that's like I [__]
love that yeah it's kind of like all
right try it don't don't judge just eat
everything again they loved it all
except for uni uh seochin which they
none of us like that is a hard bargain
yeah
it is the Marmite of Japan so I'm slowly
starting to find out now yeah Eugene
came with us as well and yeah tried uh
our friend of ours uh did he like uni no
he hated it immediately texted my Lane
saying hey I don't like sea urchin and
then Malene responded oh you probably
didn't have Goods here
aliens like Islam Michelin star yeah
yeah
this is my weekly slander yeah
um yeah uh tried um so I also we were in
uh okay so I'll tell you what we did
first of all yeah where did you take
them so uh did like uh I thought let's
because I I haven't got like super long
it's like we're still working here like
I just got off the bullet train from
bringing them back and I'd come straight
here to record
um so I wanted to make kind of a densely
packed like four or five days of no
ghost ball I hope no girl's boss sadly
that's only Sydney thing man yeah yeah
that's a tough show I also realized that
like maybe because Sydney's family is
probably a lot more outgoing than my
family like they'd probably be able to
interact themselves whereas for me it
was like I had to translate everything
and I don't even understand everything
100 of the time right just imagine your
family at a [__] girls bars the
funniest thing ever after some really
weird bars that I was insistent on going
to because I thought it'd be really fun
experience I think they're pretty fun so
the first day we went to a uh it's like
an Onsen Winery thing I think we've
talked about before so I took them to
there and they loved that that was great
yeah did they go in the answer they did
yeah
yeah like a lot of convincing no no I
just kind of like I kind of like just
didn't tell them anything about anywhere
we were going to I was like you I could
tell you but it's not gonna mean
anything yeah I told them I was like hey
go in the spa do it here we go have fun
and they I think they they were
definitely shy about it but I think they
enjoyed it yeah yeah yeah I mean who
doesn't like a hot spring it's nice yeah
yeah exactly and then the food has
really good and stuff it's lovely if
you've got a chance to go just I think I
forgot what's called just Google nigato
Winery on Sand it's chill yeah you
should check it out it's awesome this
episode is sponsored by Harrys guys do
you ever get decision fatigue with all
the choices available right now
options it can be hard to find a good
quality razor you can depend on but
Harry's makes it easy they consistently
give you better razors than in-store
options at a better price Harry razors
are refilled when you need them and they
are delivered straight to your door so
you can only choose Harry once and
they'll take care of the rest as long
time listeners of the show know by now I
have been Shilling Harry's for a long
time King so much in fact that when I
went to the UK I bought a ton of Harry
traces to bring back to me with Japan
because I refuse to use anything else
because the quality is the best let him
cook my favorite thing about Harry's is
that normally I don't have to change the
razor blade as often as other razors and
that's just nice because I'm a
cheapskate oh he cooked he took so save
the hassle set up your delivery today
and get the best quality shave with
Harry's get the 13 starter set for just
three dollars at harrys.com trash taste
that's harrys.com trash tastes for a
three dollar Starter Set Insanity get it
right now smash link contribution down
below everybody stop drop and roll this
is an emergency I have to let you know
right now that this episode is sponsored
by boxer boxer delivers the experience
of tasting authentic Japanese snacks
candies and tea sauce directly from
centuries old small family businesses
their mission is to empower Japan's
traditional stack makers by sharing
their authentic food and stories with
the world with me right now we have the
very first Boxer you will receive with
every box we purchased the seasons of
Japan box it's essentially a collection
of boxu's greatest hits so you get some
of the best snacks that boxu has to
offer right from the get-go and after
you receive this season's Japan box
every new month of boxer will be a brand
new theme with the snacks and t-pairing
fitting that theme well let's check out
this first Boxer right here uh we have
right here a zawa sabide this is kind of
like a cookie but this one is from
Okinawa and uses Okinawan black sugar
the one thing I like about these is that
they're not too sweet which is I think a
great way to kind of enjoy the little
subtleties that Japanese snacks have to
offer and you don't want to wash these
beautiful snacks down with just regular
H2O no because boxer also offers a
special tea packet that pairs with all
the snacks in the boxes and since
Mother's Day is just around the corner
why not be a good son and daughter and
give your beautiful mother a beautiful
Japanese boxer right here so what are
you waiting for click the link down in
the description below to get a boxu for
yourself and to get 15 off your own box
suit Japanese snack box use Alco
trashtaste at boxer.com that's
b-o-k-k-s-u.com
b-o-k-k-s-u.com with code trash taste
for 15 off your first order back to the
episode and then we went to Canada which
I've never been to you went to Canada
yeah why because it's kind of on the way
yeah
it's can on the way so I drove there
it's better than Toyama that's for sure
yeah yeah I thought it was like a
two-hour drive and I was like ah Church
whatever it's a four hour drive it's
long yeah and I was just like it's just
a highway the whole time and I was
losing my mind just driving straight for
like four hours it sucked but we got
there and then it started like pouring
it down and holy [__] there's so many
tourists in kanazawa really so many I
know I know was kind of like one of
those hidden tourist places uh I don't
think he's hidden well hidden in the
sense of like when you compare it to
like Tokyo dude it sounds more busy than
like uh like all soccer for tourism
really dude it was crazy how many and
you're the only person I know who's been
to come along I I I'd never been before
because I'd not heard much and then I
was like okay well I should go because
apparently there's this famous Park and
stuff yeah yeah and I went there and I
thought oh it's okay this way this is
kind of boring actually I think we hit
my head now I'm realizing yeah because
all the stuff that people talk about
that you can do in Japan it's just stuff
that's accessible only by like bullet
trains yeah exactly because like all the
good stuff in my mind you have to like
either drive to or get a train then
drive yeah like oh genuinely like a lot
of the really amazing and fun stuff in
Japan you do have to rent a car or drive
it's just so annoying I mean I mean I
kind of like that because to me it means
less tourists are there yeah I mean I I
I wouldn't disagree but I would say the
like if it's your first time in Japan
you're going to be amazed by anyway but
you know for people like living in Japan
like us where we've seen a lot of like
the more I guess like normal tourist
stuff than a more like some of the more
interesting things you have to get to by
car well I think that's why my parents
enjoyed nigato a lot because it was like
really quiet it was like no no foreign
tourists at all yeah it's really
Pleasant really good vibes very quiet
and then we went to Canada and it's like
really busy
um you know it's nice looking around the
park and stuff but I I was like I was
walking around this park and I was like
damn I think like Shinjuku Park is
better than this one and I was like and
my parents thought that too and I was
like oh [__] came all this way to this
damn Park and I think Shinjuku is better
yeah what else what else is there to do
that it's like from the park what is it
famous I've heard I've heard so many
like I know kanazawa is a really uh
famous tourist attraction for a lot of
Japanese people yeah there's a lot of
um old shopping areas I think yeah
styled off the Japanese stuff we didn't
really go to that and uh that night I I
one of my parents even though it's not
famous for it you know it's you know uh
Carlos I was famous for fish typically
yeah right um but I was like well we
should try uh we should try um uh uh eel
I was called again we should try on
Aggie and I I wasn't gonna tell them
because my my dad had mentioned like a
few days before he's like I don't like
eel and I was like okay [__] okay well
oh I don't think this is
so I was gonna not tell them that it was
eel yeah so I found this really nice
unagi restaurant that happened to be a
chain actually they had a few locations
around Japan but it was really good and
really good reviews uh and went in there
and I was like okay cool I'm not gonna
tell them it's you I'm just gonna order
a bunch of stuff sure enough we sit down
[__] everything has eels on it like
like theming wise like the Chopsticks
have a giant eel the menu is one giant
eel Scrolls and I was like all right
what do they feel parents are like and
it's all in [__] kanji yeah but I
know like what to order because I've
been to an Aggie restaurant since yeah I
got this so it's not a Neal it's a mod
fish
it's basically one of those giant like
in the cooking special where we cook
that where you can't decision right
giant Clay Pot oh yeah where they just
put all of you in agony and they put
like three portions in that instead of
doing three little boxes that sounds
good and uh it was super [__] good
yeah and my parents loved it they were
like yeah this shit's good did you tell
them afterwards yeah I told them I told
them I was ill and they were like oh
yeah we kind of figured out
who gave it away I just thought it was a
fail proof yeah they were like oh it
tastes like chicken I was like wow okay
I've done all my life but they loved it
they had a great time uh and they I
think the counter sale was all right I
mean I was kind of like this I was lame
yeah but I think like for one day I is
just like one of those prefectures you
don't really hear a people going to and
be like what's like known in that prefix
because like you know Japan always has
that thing of like oh in this prefecture
we're famous for this this and this
where it's like you hear about Ishq and
it's like what are you famous for it's
like we have kanazawa it's like yeah
okay but what's this it's like yeah I
mean I I think it's I I feel like I've
traveled enough of Japan now to be a bit
uh be able to like kind of rate some of
the places I mean I've got like a [__]
ton of places here so I feel like I can
accurately tell you what's a fun place
and what's not I guess I was okay also
it was raining so it was also just
coming okay as well yeah yeah it doesn't
it definitely affects your judgment and
then we went to Kyoto the day after ah
how was that how many tourists yeah oh
my god dude because I I've only been to
Kyoto now
during the pandemic and I've been three
times during the pandemic and it's time
it was slowly busier than the last it
was never busy yeah like the first time
I went and you can watch this in my um
when I did the British town but yeah we
it's in Kyoto this British town and we
filmed at the Kyo mizudera the the the
picture of Japan and every single
tourist picture
yeah yeah and and you can see in that
video actually like we filmed the thing
and you can see in the background
there's nobody there there's no one at
this Temple
um and it was it was like really cool
and I thought oh this is kind of neat
and I went there this time I was like I
never want to go to Kidder ever again
this [__] sucks like it's like shoulder
to shoulder yeah the whole thing like
you can't you can't do anything fun
there was actually a pretty cool
um Craft Beer Stand like right at the
bottom of the street right before the
kill music that was kind of cool it was
and it's a good beer it was like
standing thing it was kind of fun other
than that but everything else was like
okay the views were cool I think they
enjoyed that
um uh yeah we went around temples but
dude I got recognized so much it's kind
of like all right I felt bad for my
parents because in the kill music we got
stopped like nine times just walking
around there's nowhere to go as well
because this is like everywhere shoulder
to shoulder but I think my parents kind
of they they kind of got a kick out of
seeing people recognize me they're like
oh
I've done this three times before yeah I
would if my friends were like hey Connor
let's go to Kyoto let's go look at
Temple I'm like absolutely not like I
I'll I'll come out and drink later yeah
it's like have a good time
to get recognized I don't give a [__]
about that it's just a dude it's so busy
for me yeah I just I don't enjoy it even
even for people who are like okay in a
crowd like just how packed Kyoto gets
especially at Nara as well like those
those like I think are like the top two
places where it's like it's literally
like going to an anime convention it's
just like you're [__] standing like
this and it's like and you can't even
get like a good view because you have to
[__] look over the heads of everyone
it's just like is this is it an age
thing where you just like I don't know
if it is but it has been for me because
I used to be like so up for like going
into big crowds or you know seven age
thing yeah yeah and then the more older
I got the less patience I had for like
big groups of people to the point where
now I would do anything to just avoid it
if I can I think it's an age thing
because I think all three of us are
there
we're just like yeah okay here's if
there's a giant crowd it needs to be
something that makes the giant crowd in
my mind worth the sacrifice yeah yeah
yeah exactly something about this is
like such moving but something about not
being able to walk the pace I want to
walk just just gets to me and it's just
it's such a small thing but if there's a
[__] penguin walk right like yeah
yeah little little tiny baby steps yeah
if you just penguin walk like uh because
when we went to uh Shibuya like last
weekend yeah and you were like uh where
are you and uh I was like oh I'm just
around the corner 10 minutes later he
text me again being like where are you
and I literally was just like penguin
Walking In This Crowd I was literally
just around the corner and I'm like
shibia never again never [__] again
that that's shoulders
oh my God and they told me it was too
busy yeah I was like yeah okay well yeah
that's the point yeah like the crossing
was really busy yeah of course it is
um and uh yeah every night we went out
as well security we went out and luckily
I had a friend who
um was from Kyoto who I I hang out with
a few times when I went last time and
they'd show me a bunch of bars so it was
great excite a bunch of bars that I knew
that were great yeah they were good
vibes and I like it when they're like
not on the street and a lot of these
bars weren't so it's great because you
can actually always get in yeah
um and then um which if you cocktail
bars and then I was like okay I got an
idea I want to take them I just looked
on my phone I was like is there an
airsoft Barn nearby and there seems to
be an airsoft bar in like every city
yeah it was fun yeah and so we I found
an airsoft bot it looks super Jank they
did like tacos and shisha and Airsoft
it's just like a weird combination it
was in Kyoto about it it's really
peaceful like Kyoto apparently The
Nightlife area of Kyoto is like pretty
wild like oh yeah it's very loud and
touristy can't say I think in general is
like very loud so I was like yeah I
found this bar and I was like [__] it
let's go so I took my parents to the
shooting bar and I'm like yeah pick a
gun we'll go shoot we'll shoot it in the
shooting range so I'm like you have a
Japanese experience yeah
not getting what's happening yeah my
dad's like all right I'll shoot this one
my mom's like I don't I don't want to
shoot anything just shoot a gun shooter
so she picks like the like the Desert
Eagle or something yeah and then they
stick her in this range I think she
really enjoyed it she was having a good
time yeah I picked like the most big gun
I was like give me the biggest one you
got so the grenade launcher yeah they
gave me like some giant assault rifle
thing and I just started [__] they
were all like they were okay and I was
like all right let me show you how it
sounds like I was like that's gaming and
I did pretty good of course but yeah but
more importantly uh there is such a
weird bar and then after that I was like
we've got to find some weird ass salary
Man karaoke bar that isn't on the street
right it's gonna be on like the fourth
floor yeah and I found this bar with it
was this is a weird karaoke bar
um that was like a mismatch of like
there was like a tatami area with like
game consoles and there was like lawn
chairs in this other Corner because my
parents wanted to do karaoke and at
first they were like no no I don't want
to do any songs and I was like yeah I'll
sing I'll sing so sang and then
eventually they were kind of like I
guess we'll do one song and then they
got two into it and I was like all right
we're gonna go now stop stop queuing
songs and she's like yeah we'll go we'll
go and then as we're standing up my
mom's putting in another [__] song I
mean mom we gotta go
please yeah yeah and they just love
karaoke and the I think the Japanese uh
bar owner was like what the [__] is
going what the [__] is this because our
friend came with us as well and he was
[__] awful at singing and he was
screaming I of course Eugene would be of
course of course he would be off Pitch
he doesn't strike me as a bit of a scene
yeah he was like all off Pitch screaming
and then this guy was smoking his
cigarettes before we came in in a moment
when our friend started singing he was
like all right I'm out see ya I just
laughed
and I went in the toilet and it was I
posted on Twitter of the tiny ass uh
toilet and I'm taking a piss and just a
cockroach just walks over my foot and I
was like yeah that seems about right
yeah I was like oh God you're all right
at home oh God you know I kind of love
the vibe of those bars you find it no I
do I love them because you know there
are so many bars nowadays where you know
people think about oh what's the concept
of this bar what's the selling point of
this bar and then you find places like
the airsoft shisha place and it's just
like some guy drunk at 3M being like
dude they were like just Bros yeah yeah
super chill they were like what do you
want to do yeah I was like I feel like
opening up ball what should we have that
ball [__] Airsoft
it was like a weird mural on the wall of
like attack helicopters and juice it was
really weird it was clearly everything
but Japanese yeah it was just the
weirdest [__] bar when I think it's
Japan I think of Airsoft tacos and [__]
well it's like that's what I'm saying
like I'm like let's go to the weird bars
like I think they really enjoyed that
yeah some like really nice ones really
like good sit-down ones but also a bunch
of weird ones yeah and the next day we
uh oh dude like I was pretty shocked I
my parents like how are we getting to
All Star Girls I don't know I'll figure
it out in the morning it can't be and I
took this for granted like I think
people when they come to Japan like they
feel really like intimidated by like
transporting getting places yeah and I
guess because we've just done it so
goddamn much it's like dude there's
always a way yeah you don't need to
worry about it you can figure it out in
the morning yeah and like luckily
because I I knew that
um uh also I can get super close I was
like yeah sure there's 30 minutes away
yeah I'm sure there's like commuter
trains and you can get so I was like
don't worry about it and there happened
to be a train station in like uh that
had this train that went all the way
there and it was more of like a it was
kind of like a hybrid between a commuter
train and like a shinkansen where it was
like all the trains were laid out like
uh like shinkansen's where you get like
a seat and table yeah and I found this
train I don't know why I'm gonna be like
a trainer for a second I even though I
don't normally care I so we went to this
like normal ass train right
and then we go down to the platform and
there was like this kiosk on the
platform where you could buy tickets to
the premium car the green car not the
green car because this is like a
different line entirely right right they
had their own branding and [__] and it
was like a kiosk it was like if you want
to go in the premium car you're going to
pay to upgrade here and I thought okay
[__] it let's see what it is so go up to
the thing uh bear in mind this whole
journey from uh Kyoto to Osaka it was
like 300 Yen yeah uh because it's like a
normal ass Transportation train super
close
um and so I thought okay well how much
could it be like so I go to this thing
and it's it's 500 yen to upgrade to this
like luxury train I thought oh let's do
it sure let's see what it is we get in
dude it's like the nicest thing ever
it's like this train is immaculate these
seats are incredible and had like a
chauffeur in the [__] seat I couldn't
believe this thing wow I was like 500
yen in the UK this would cost like 400
quid yeah just to upgrade to this I was
like holy [__] dude it was so cool I
just and I just got such a like that
made me so happy just finding that out
and that we just got on that thing and
it was super nice and not the first
class of commuter trains it's just
randomly found this premium s and I
wouldn't have found it unless I just
happened to walk past that section of
the car because they had these two
things so you could just pay with your
suitcase upgrade it I thought dude
that's sick and then the moment you walk
onto the premium car there's like
someone is like immediately like shove
your tickets to enter the premium car
he's all dressed up like a like really
fancy yeah yeah this is sick this is so
sick oh yeah character and uh sorry I
got to Osaka did that and uh yeah walked
around or soccer took them to like the
Pokemon Center there thoughts on body
because they were like they wanted to
buy stuff for like nephews and stuff and
dude there was a line of like 200 people
to buy stuff something like this or
something of course there would be yeah
yeah
there was a retro arcade and I was like
you should come you should check out
some retro arcade I thought they weren't
gonna like it much but my dad was he was
just playing Gallagher for like an hour
yeah
it's like okay I can still play Metal
Slug until he's done I was I was like
I'm chill with this chill out just
crushing it yeah yeah yeah I took him to
almost like a castle which is probably
my favorite touristy thing that I did it
looks like a castle was kind of sick I I
a lot of the touristy stuff in Japan I
either haven't done or have done and
thought it was kind of meh yeah because
a lot of it's super overrated or super
Rams um but also like a castle actually
the view from it was really cool and all
the historical stuff uh was uh really
cool and quite interesting although
there was like two floors of the castle
which you weren't allowed to photograph
and I don't know why that I'm wondering
what the rules are behind this but this
dude had the worst job ever he had a
giant no photography sign and whenever
anyone tried to take a photo or whipped
it out he would scream and run across
selling no photo no photo and I can't I
just imagine myself like man what a [__]
job yeah just every tourist known to man
your job is to figure out what goddamn
language to shout at them in because
people are gonna take photos yeah
they're just gonna do it like is this
just how it is and it should make me
think like what is the what is the
thought process behind not a lot that
guy impact ain't getting paid enough man
dude nowhere near enough but also
polyglot goes to the efforts 12
languages and he gets that job you've
got to figure out like you're like damn
I I think you just defaults to English
on everyone yeah I don't understand why
they we couldn't take pictures of it
because we should Miniatures of the
castle Yeah I was just in my head I'm
like I don't I
I don't know like people are gonna take
pictures like crazy of course I don't
know if I'm just being like a cynical
I'm like maybe you should just let him
take pictures I mean Japan's rules
concerning like no photography is like
it can be quite agreeing it's confusing
because it's just only those two floors
yeah but the view from the castle is
amazing uh if you ever get the chance to
go to Osaka I mean I'd recommend it I'd
it also that Deal's great yeah yeah I I
normally I I never do the touristy
stocks I think it's so lame
um but this one actually was it's
probably the best view of all soccer as
well you get such a cool panoramic view
the whole uh whole city also Osaka is
just a really fun city yeah yeah so
um I took them to at night I took them
body and they were like yeah I guess
I've seen it at movies before they were
kind of underwhelmed by it they're like
yeah I guess it's kind of cool I mean I
guess yeah it is just just lights in it
yeah I get it you know one impressed by
the giant [__] crab mechanical thing
that they have and like one of the crab
stores oh we didn't go past that one I
didn't know I just tempted the I we
walked along the river yeah yeah yeah
um and uh yeah then then we went out to
drinking and it was fun I mean also
people are pretty fun yeah I think I
went to the one bar
there was just only foreigners by
accident uh
like we went out of this cocktail bar
and I thought sick dude I found a sick
cocktail bar yeah and so we walk in and
there's just like one of the tourist
person in there yeah so in the time
we're drinking our wandering the entire
Place fills with tourists yeah and I was
like damn this not not that there's
anything wrong with that because I mean
technically you wanted to give them like
a Japanese I was like I don't even find
them a cool spot and I thought I found a
cool spot yeah but obviously I don't
live in Osaka and then of course I just
found the one where it's [__]
everyone every goddamn tourist found
yeah um but then I found this really
cool like if you're looking I I got this
this ad for this part it looks so weird
and I was like dude I was like I don't
know if we should go but our friend
Museum was like we should go but I was
kind of like I don't know so it was
called a Magic Bar okay that sounds like
a very Eugene thing yeah so then here's
the deal here's the deal so we found it
right I saw it and I was like I don't
know yeah and then his story he's like
we should go check it out and I'm like
yeah
it's in like literally on the Alley that
has just all of the sex stuff yeah right
and
um it's on like the fifth floor of a
really dirty ass building
you know and it's like one of like six
bars on this fifth floor of this tiny
building so there's like Max five seats
and the thing is and this is what had me
worried was that if you sit down on this
Magic Bar you had to sit there for 70
minutes because you're paying for 70
minutes of magic regardless oh okay yeah
so he does a little show for you yeah
you drink and it's like okay like the
bartender is a magician and it was like
3500 Yen each per person to sit down and
the bartender's a magician yeah now I I
was like I this could be either the best
thing ever or just the weirdest thing
ever yeah and so he's like we should
check it out I'm fine fine I'll check it
out I'll I'll and again I'm the vibe
check I have to go in see if they're
cool with a white guy walking in and you
know even I'm talking you know and I was
I'll explain to Eugene I'm like listen
there's like QuickTime events the first
three sentences matter so much in these
bars you have to nail every interaction
in Japanese for them to be comfortable
if you don't have communication 100 yeah
all the first three questions I'll ask
you all the first three sentences
because otherwise they'll get super
nervous and they'll be like actually no
don't sit down sorry we're reserved or
yeah one of the excuses right so you
need to nail it and I'm like oh God I
hate I hate doing this because like it's
just annoying because then I I'm like I
talk to them and then I'm like here are
my very foreign people with me you know
as if it's me and then it's like
everyone else speaks Japanese it's kind
of easier yeah yeah you know but if I'm
gonna be the translator and sometimes
and also like this is a different
dialect as well yeah I don't understand
what they're saying and it's kind of
awkward but anyway we go in this bar and
there's no one in here and it looks like
a just a normal ass weird bar yeah it
was just like it's just a bar with a
bunch of random stuff in it sure and uh
he seems kind of interesting this guy
and he was called like oh [__] I had the
business card oh he has a magic name he
has a magic name but it's his name but
magic in front of it so it's his surname
white Magic Mike
Magic Mike and we walk in and the guy's
like kind of friendly yeah uh a little
bit precarious at first but then he kind
of warms up and he's like okay cool like
you're okay with the he was he explained
the rule again that we read on the
Google that was like yeah are you cool
with the 3 500 yeah I don't wanna like
you know yeah it's fine yeah
and so he's kind of getting ready he
makes his a drink and then he he like
he's like here play with this thing and
he puts like this thing the useless box
have you seen this thing before that's
where you push it and then the thing
comes out and just pushes it back yeah
oh yeah it's like this and I was like oh
God this is it is this like the vibe
while he's getting ready just gives us
this and he tells my mum to just push it
forward and I'm like okay man Push It
Forward I should just presses it
downwards and obviously nothing happens
because you should push forward yeah
like mum Push It Forward how do you [__]
up the one thing you have to sorry
anyway so he's doing that and then he's
still preparing some stuff and then he
comes back out takes his useless box
puts his other thing and it's like a
coffin and you press the button and then
just this eye opens and the little thing
goes
I'm like what the [__] is this bar dude
what is the concept for the Magic Bar
was like you walk in it's like all right
poof your money
I was like [__] this is this is uh
that's the [__] you give to
four-year-olds to be like yeah entertain
yourself you know dude this man is
really [__] shutting the ball low
yeah this is this is weird like and then
[Music]
he like he goes back because he's like a
little curtain in the bar separating
like one third of the bar where I guess
all his shit's in there yeah so it goes
in this curtain and my my mom is like
looking terrified she's like can we go
or something I'm like no we've paid now
we have this we committed yeah we're
seeing how the show is turning out
he just he just goes back in and then
he's like silently walks in like a mime
and then he just smiles and in his teeth
are just glow up teeth
it's just and he just starts making
noises and I came out with the grills
and I'm like oh [__] is this
I'm like oh God oh God and you paid how
much for this
3500 yeah I'm like oh God this is gonna
be terrible this is gonna be so bad
and then um
again goes back into the closet comes
back out and I I can't remember how this
all kicked off uh but he's uh he's he
he like whips out his wallet and it's a
Louis Vuitton and he opens his wallet
and it's just it just sets a blaze right
it's just all that's all the money that
he took from them but yeah it's like
here's your money right now
to his credit right like this whole time
he's like doing really fun playful
English he's English would be pretty
good yeah to keep my parents engaged in
my friend and I was like oh [__] I
didn't make job being like all right
okay oh that's all my money gone all
right okay I should do the magic now and
then close as well I don't know why he
did this then you started doing card
tricks and the card tricks are pretty
[__] good he started doing like
really good like all right is this your
card kind of thing yeah yeah it was
pretty standard stuff and it was like oh
it was pretty good all right this guy
ain't bad all right and then he started
doing these tricks
um and he slowly got better and better
and started doing better tricks it was
really [__] cool and then he started
doing this thing I don't know if you've
ever seen magicians do this where they
have like two elastic bands right and
they keep somehow connecting them and
disconnect oh yes oh yes yeah and he was
naughty at it like actually actually
insane he would get my parents to hold
the elastic band tight and closed and
somehow he'd keep connecting it and
disconnecting yeah yeah and it was like
okay this guy's pretty [__] it's all
right he's pretty cracked and then
between like every like set of so he
would do like a bunch of different magic
tricks with like one thing and then he
would kind of like he'd be like all
right who wants a drink and then he'd
make drinks and then he would start the
next kind of it was actually pretty
[__] kid I've seen those magic bars
for years now I thought they were so
[__] I've always been curious to go into
it yeah yeah but now I know I need
multiple pass one one time
and we were like should we try it out
and we're just like oh it's really
tempting yeah it looks so stupid yeah
they always look sketchable they always
charge a massive fee for yeah and then
I'm always like I don't know and then he
did those tricks dude it was so he was
actually [__] nuts then he started
doing like the whole
um the classic where you have like a
ring and then he keeps somehow getting
it on and off his finger with like
sleight of hands yeah yeah and then he
brought out like a rope and then a wand
and then he would somehow like you'd
have to like I don't know it was maybe
it was like basic magic but he was
really [__] good how intoxicated were
you I was not that interesting that's
the important question he was he was to
his credit his acting charge was pretty
good and he was putting on a show he was
pretty funny all right and then uh at
the end he did like uh yeah yeah he did
a few tricks that were really [__]
cool I thought like he did one way like
put the like a full-on nail like a giant
nail up his nose oh yes you like hammer
it and stuff and then it appeared and
then like okay is this your card and
then it you know it wouldn't be the card
and to his credit like he his acting was
really [__] good because I thought
he'd [__] up and then he just didn't
[__] up and then somehow he he he's like
no no this is mistake this is a mistake
I have to uh a banish card and then he
starts eating the card right and then he
just like whips it out of like inside of
a pouch inside of a pouch inside of a
pouch yeah he's like a visual card I was
like what the [__] that's so cool it was
really good it was a really good man I
think it's just literally called Magic
Bar in uh Osaka so that's what most of
them yeah check it out it was [__]
fun it was great my parents loved it and
then uh yeah that was a fun night out in
Osaka I didn't go crazy because you know
if I took him to like a girls bar or bar
we have to talk more Japanese people it
would just be me translating for like
three people and yeah yeah like it's a
lot it's exhausting first time
it's like [__] I just wanted a drink of
course yeah no because you've got to
play caretaker because you dude I did
but I was like how do I make experiences
they don't rely on me translating
because you want to have fun as well
yeah I want to not be exhausted yeah you
know everyone knows I'm driving showing
them around and I'm just translating all
day and it's like oh my God it's tough
yeah you forget especially like after
taking care of people how much you just
take for granted in terms of how you
know like the way the country functions
for sure like you know when you get
asked like the littlest thing for every
thing that kind of like adds up and adds
up and adds up yeah every single time
yeah they asked me especially if your
dad is asking what beer this is
um like they had cover charge in one
place because current charge is pretty
common in Japan yeah yeah 500 to 1000
yen you get a snack or something and my
dad was like did I did I get scammed and
I was like no no it's
it's normal but it uses on guard with
everything yeah yeah like an ATM he's
like is that ATM safe and I was like
they're all safe every ATM's safe I mean
I get where it's concerned because it's
not all safe yeah I told him I'm like
everything's safe here don't worry like
anything it's all good it's all safe no
one's trying to scam you no one's trying
to do anything Japan's probably well
like one of the countries in Asia where
you can feel most at home feeling safe
not getting scammed just stay away from
the back streets of shinjuk and shubia
you'll be good yeah yeah just don't say
yes if someone asks you to come to the
bar and you're probably like safe yeah
yeah I told them to go to saksa as well
I didn't want to go with them because I
was like this oh I was really busy
yeah yeah I took Sid's parents there
yeah that's it yeah I mean it's like
Kyoto and just like one one little area
in Tokyo it's kind of tough because I
don't think they have much interest in
temples or stuff like that they
appreciate it but they're not like
they're not they don't really they're
not seeking it yeah I think you should
go check it out it's kind of interesting
yeah and then they were like what's with
all this um with all the smoke stuff I
was like oh what they're like yeah in
Australia everyone's blowing smoke on
themselves like what are you what I was
like oh they meant like when they put
the incense in the thing and then they
yeah you know yeah they kept asking me
what all the when we went to Kyoto they
were like what is all this stuff with
they're trying to why why they always
want money I was like I said I guess God
needs money I don't know I don't know
this table isn't paying for itself yeah
and I was like damn they know the upkeep
you know yeah they were they didn't want
to get their fortunes tons like oh we
should get up we should get our thought
she was told she's got unfortunately
told and my mum got bad fortune she's
like this is why I didn't want my
fortune top I always get bad fortunes
and I was like no it's fun it's fun to
find it you remind me because we I did
the same thing with like Sid's parents
as well same thing mom mom got the bad
fortune and she was like I can't believe
it of course my fortune is bad and I'm
like we need to just tie it up then she
so she starts tying it up and she's like
gonna buy another Fortune is is that is
that part of the game and it's just I
want to be double blessed actually yeah
and I'm just like Mom you're a true
gacha gamer that right now you've
realized anything can be good luck if
you have enough money exactly I thought
she just kept going until she got the
Good Luck Charlie she whales for The
Good Wife
oh my God and I'm like that's my mom I'm
so jealous that you guys have to have to
get to have these experiences because I
I can't do that with my parents yeah
yeah right it's like my mom is like
already so familiar with her my dad's
come to Japan like [__] 30 times in
his lifetime so I'm just like I don't
have that like immediate you know thing
of like let me show you the wonders of
this country that I love kind of deal
right because it's like I've done it
with my you know friends who have never
come to Japan and stuff like that but
it's different right yeah it's different
but oh but I will say it is it never
gets old seeing someone who's never been
to Japan or never been to Asia and just
seen Japan and just like blowing their
minds at the most [__] like senseless
things ever yeah for no apparent reason
you know like when I took like my
University friends to Kyoto for instance
like my my friend just like one time we
were on our way to Human and he just
stopped at a [__] like a vending
machine but it wasn't just one vending
machine it was like six vending machines
all in a row and he was like taking
photos of this I'm like it's a [__]
video machine that we walked past like
20 of them and he was like yeah but the
six of them I'm like
why am I taking you all the way they
were impressed uh so if you have a drive
in Japan you stop at one of the service
stations they were impressed by the
giant you've seen these right the giant
coffee machines oh yeah yeah they have
these massive coffee machines that make
like like kind of fresh coffee uh in
like a cup and it's all like timed and
this one has a screen showing you the
coffee
just a cup it was just like okay but
they were kind of impressed by that
they're like this is pretty good
um parents also not very good with
chopsticks
um
he's better than my mom he'll probably
want that three sets oh they tried they
tried it was tough it was tough we had
um with some gyoza yeah that was kind of
tough oh there's a slippery bug yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I was like we
should try all that because my favorite
girls are placed as um
they they do uh they do the yucky girls
are the normal type but then they also
do the if you want to try they can do
the deep fried uh boiled and the normal
yeah yeah so they would mum was it was
like watching like the Looney Tunes like
moment when I'm trying to pick up the
The Boiled gyoza
slipping us splashing in the soy sauce
and I felt so bad and I could see my mom
was getting more stressed out I'm sorry
she's like how do you get good at this
I'm like I don't remember ever being
good I don't remember ever being like
not able to do this yeah I don't know I
and I realized now that not having
Chopsticks enough not you know learning
Chopsticks does kind of I mean take a
while if you're if you've never used it
um but credits my parents they they keep
trying yeah they don't they don't they
never like ask for a knife and fork
would be like where is it yeah I
remember the first place we went to this
um brought them on knife and fork and
like I think your dad was like no I will
not admit defeats and I was like yeah
that's going as that all right
damn no well I think that's the best
thing right it's like it's just the fact
that I think the one thing I always
appreciate about whenever I'm taking
people to Japan or you know wherever is
that like if if they're just like even
willing they don't even have to like it
the fact the fact that they're just
willing to participate in the culture is
like the best thing
they're trying everything and then that
you know appreciating every aspect of
the culture which I'm very fun I knew
they would but you know in your head
you're always worried you're like oh man
they you know they they don't really
care that much about Japan so yeah yeah
they wouldn't yeah well the one thing
that I think is the hardest and even for
me this is kind of tough is that
you have to resist that urge to let the
taxi driver pick up your luggage because
sometimes the Dude Looks like he's like
90. he's like half your size and he's
going to pick up your heavy ass suitcase
yeah yeah and like ah dude it's like
it's it's you can obviously pick it up
like he's fine to do it and it's like
it's sometimes just easier I'm like just
let him let him do it trust me it's
gonna be so annoying if you like if you
had this problem sometimes when you when
you try to put your luggage in and
they're like no I want to do it and it's
like this whole thing of like okay oh
I've had the opposite happen where like
it was a super super old guy like frail
as [__] trying to pick up my luggage and
he like went to grab it he didn't even
like try to lift this thing up he
literally just grabbed the handle for
about two seconds and then just let go
he looked at me he's like
I think it's like the like Asian kid in
me because my parents are like pretty
old now so I've gotten used to being
like no dad for [__] sake you're in
your 70s yeah let me carry them I always
want to do it yeah yeah so I'm like
every time I get to the taxi I'm ready
for like a little not not a fight but
like I'm ready to fight him to let me
know like give me that [__] okay get in
the taxi okay I'm a young healthy man I
can do this okay don't worry about it
yeah I mean I try to do that and if it's
if it is actually heavy I'm like dude no
yeah no don't do it yeah it's like light
I'm like all right it's okay fine yeah
of course yeah yeah because it's like
sometimes especially at least for my
parents I told them to do that because I
was like don't you're not gonna be able
to communicate with them it's gonna be
awkward just just just let them do it
yeah yeah and then also let them cook do
not do not open the doors don't close
the doors don't open the door oh it does
just don't and this is the hardest thing
to tell people because I feel like you
can tell them and they just don't they
don't do it because it's like it's it's
something in your brain it's hardwired
yeah where you open the door and you
close the door to the taxi yeah but like
I was like do not touch the doors I know
you want to don't do it they will open
it for you so they they're kind of
getting used to it and stuff I don't get
it it's it's tough It's hard traveling
outside of Japan and unlearning that the
amount of [__] times I've traveled
out and I've just for one second walk
straight out of an Uber and just not
looked back yeah it's just it it happens
every single time I like I've had the
opposite where like I walk up to the
Uber I'm just standing in front of it
just waiting for it to open I'm just
like oh yeah yeah right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um so they're getting used to it what uh
what are you planning for to do with
them for like the rest of your time for
a few more days someone just came to
some nice restaurants
golden guy uh I might I'm I'm do I I I
gotta stop drinking
my parents they like drinking so it's
like I'm like I'm like dying but no
drinking please
um yeah pretty well I realized as well
like I don't mind eating out at a nice
restaurant
um but obviously to be a good son I want
to pay for them yeah and I'm like oh my
God paying for me for a nice restaurant
every now and then is fine yeah paying
for three people for a nice restaurant
every day back back to back I'm like oh
my God I'm just adding up I'm like I'm
broke here my accountant's asking me uh
uh so what's going on Connor how many
business dinners do you have yeah 600 on
a on a tempura restaurant color really
one of the because I'm like man you got
to try it and I'm like ah it's only
they're only here one time I should yeah
of course okay
so yeah I'm do you think they're gonna
come back at any time in the future yeah
I think they definitely want to go
skiing yeah yeah that'll be awesome I
think I think they want to learn how to
be a bit more independent here It's just
tough because I think learning it's
understandable learning languages uh
yeah at Old ages is hot and I think no
matter how many times I mean Steven I'm
I'm still you know it's still hard to do
it
telling someone how to Sumi Masen is
[__]
ing a Brit uh telling a British person
to see myself
still can't do it we're in a bar right
and you know it's gonna be nice where
they're gonna be out without me yeah and
I was like man I gotta teach you how to
swim in my sand like you've got to just
do it yeah you got it you gotta learn
because if you want a beer you gotta you
gotta you want to get an attention right
like if you want to be it and you want
it right now you've got to swim in my
sound yeah so I told them I was like all
right try it say Sumi Masen and so they
go oh super I'm like no no no louder not
even me when I go when I go like see my
sand they won't hear me it's like it's
gonna be even more yeah yeah
do it and then when they come over just
say just say beeru it's okay you don't
need to say any other stuff they'll they
understand you've seen a little just say
it a little bit and they're like okay
okay and they try and
my dad's so bad at it he I could tell
him what to say here and he'll just
think it'll all just forget the moment
he's enjoyed like no I just say beer one
more please and I'm like Dad
[Music]
yeah I can't imagine my parents being
able to learn that my parents are the
most like reserved people on this on
this planet yeah my mum's got this book
that's Japanese phrases book and she's
using it sometimes I don't know how well
it's working out first right uh she says
it's working well I've been teaching
them like the uh phrases that need to be
used aside I'm like I try to
well at one time I I told them I was
like hey come you know I was like
because I was like hey come come to my
apartment building no no I'll come to
your side because they were staying
super close by and so
um I go down to my apartment building
and they're they're just talking to
someone to a Japanese person outside my
apartment building what the [__] are
they doing
so I go out and this is a woman looking
really confused right and then I'm
guessing my mom was trying to confirm
that this was the address and I was like
Mom I was like I was like I see myself
and then so then she she'd laugh and I
was like whatever don't don't talk to
people thinking they're not gonna
they're not gonna speak any English
especially in Tokyo
it was it was very wholesome but I was
like oh god oh no they're they've been
here like two days in order like
confronting strangers I was like oh God
your mom just whips out the book it's
like it's my time and I was like oh my
God
they're so cute yeah this episode is
sponsored by grammarly gentlemen do you
want the English good I do do you want
the English better than we're englishing
now yes please well grammarly is for you
boys as a certified CEO I have to write
a lot of emails to clients and there is
no worse feeling than writing an email
to a business partner and sounding
unprofessional as heck thankfully
grammarly is there to help me write the
most confidence and pristine
professional emails if only I had family
when I worked with the BBC well
grammarly premiums confident tone
suggestions ensure you come across as
confident capable and short when the
stakes are high and you're crunch for
time writing to your colleague can get
misinterpreted especially when it can be
interpreted in the wrong tone I'm
looking at you every British email
that's ever existed so you can download
grammarly which easily integrates into
your daily life it works where you work
such as Google Docs Microsoft Word to
ensure your tone is coming across the
way you wanted to the right tone can
move your projects forward with the help
of grammarly so go to grambly.com trash
taste to sign up for an account and if
you'd like to level up your writing and
tone upgrade to grammarly premium for 20
off that's gravely.com trashtaste back
to the episode is Eugene still going
through his little weeb phase yes he's
usually pretty good at saying stuff
yeah and then when he gets a period he
goes be rudes
yeah
everything Eugene Eugene is that one
person who went to Japan after watching
200 anime yeah right like the first two
critical credit do yeah here's he is
trying yeah he's trying right just you
don't have to say like Bureau dance
after you get us like yeah we know we
[__] got it for you yeah the first
thing every time there's an order come
that comes out I remember like going to
dinner with them and every time an order
would come out you know we're
and I was like Eugene
we're in a public setting here you just
said that is fried chicken that is meat
yes he's the type of guy who just like
sees what he sees in Genki and just like
immediately reflects the background like
this is
okay Eugene is a Vietnamese yeah so uh
these taxi drivers just weren't stopping
for me and I was like I bet it's some
[__] white I'm like Eugene stand in
front of me and Haley cause you're in
Kyoto and I was like yeah no they're
probably just tired of [__] [__]
tourists yeah and I was like from a
distance Eugene they might think you're
Japanese hail them sure enough hellborn
immediately got a cab right let me take
over
I was like I'm sick of this [__] the
Asian baby it works every time
she's just gone up here
[__]
I was like [__] this [__] but also
that's kind of hype
to you know if I walk in they'll be like
what the [__] what is this white guy
doing wait when when we were in 30 yeah
do we do it and we make sometimes Joey
make we make Joey walk in because Joey
you know out of all of us look at the
Motions
yeah but there's also that 0.5 seconds
of panic from where the moment they look
at my face and they're just like oh God
yeah cause you've got a beard you know
as soon as he as soon as this
but he looks more Japanese than us so
that's you know that helps yeah with me
for sure and it's not that I won't get a
seat it's that like I just wanna you
know why would you stack the cards you
know what I mean yeah make it easier for
me it's like why play on hard difficult
why play on legendary difficulty when I
can play on normal videos you know it's
just always that panic when I walk into
a bar and there's like five seconds of
panic on their face and yeah to be like
immediately after you talk more than I
normally would yeah yeah my first
Japanese would be no questions asked but
immediately just start being like Oh
you're on me yeah yeah yeah yeah I have
to do this thing now where like because
there's that 0.5 seconds a panic from
seeing my face the moment
immediately just start talking yeah I
don't even give them a shadow of a Down
this is the Strat by the way if you do
if you are a foreign person uh you know
and you do know a little bit of Japanese
if you do actually want to get into some
bars where they might be a bit like no
you just have to immediately
yeah
oh okay
I've noticed ever since like I've grown
like a little stubble I've I've I guess
I've like stopped being like mistaken
for Asian in Asian countries I don't
know what it is about the beard before
it was kind of like 50 50 you know I had
the tan skin but sometimes you know
maybe I'll be mistaken for a local like
even in it's actually no especially in
[__] Thailand yeah like I remember I
remember this one time I was
um I was at a restaurant and you know
same same kind of Strat you go in you uh
kind of like have to like start speaking
Thai straight away and if you don't then
they're gonna think you're a foreigner
yeah so just just this day you know I
was uh uh I went I went into this
restaurant with like a few friends uh
just kind of like forgot I was just like
little space cadet that day and uh
person asked me uh you know wait uh
waitress asked me a question uh just
didn't hear it I was like sorry and I I
know you know out of instinct and I was
like immediately like oh no sorry and
then I started speaking to her but just
just that just that millisecond of just
just the sorry and then she she
immediately just flipped into this guy
as a tourist right and then and so I um
I start explaining to her hey I want
this I want that and she uh in Thai by
the way in like in local time she she's
just like uh my my no you need to do
this and I was just like and and I was
like I understand yeah this is what I
want again in Thai and she just she
would just refuse she she refused I get
that so often yeah man it's not even
funny like the mo like the you know I
understand like the initial reaction
they see my face they're like oh you're
not Japanese looking so I'll start
speaking in just the most broken English
possible yeah start explaining [__] and
then I respond back being like awesome
on this there yeah and then they're like
yes so anyway
[__] I just spoke Japanese I understand
[__] I am one of you yeah and I refuse
to leave this place until I'm treated
that way it is fun seeing the like
relieved look when you're like oh
yeah yeah
it's like nature is like healing it's
carrying all back oh my God
amazing okay question uh Jerry because
you've been in the situation forever
when you see when you're like checking
into a hotel maybe you're out somewhere
and you see like somebody who's like
English speaking having like a lot of
difficulty uh with whatever they're
doing do you ever like help or you like
um
[Music]
it's uh it's probably 50 50. okay but
like sometimes like you know if I'm say
like at a hotel right and the person in
front of me is like foreign and then you
know kind of struggling then it's like
well I want to get checked in so I'll
help him out they've seen him in front
of you yeah but if they're like another
person yeah off to the side I'm just
like couldn't be me
I was just like I just came back to be
like let's see let's see how they
resolve this let's see how they passed
this test so it's a case by case I think
but like you know like there's every now
and then you know like I it could be
maybe be like in a Tokyo station or
something and I see like a family that's
like clearly struggling to get around
and then sometimes if I have time I'll
be like oh you're okay like let me help
you out stuff like that uh yeah but it
depends on my mood really like or if I'm
like I don't know if you're busy like I
get it you got to go somewhere yeah yeah
exactly but sometimes I just kind of sit
back and be like I want to see how they
figure it out
I had a few interactions right there was
like one coffee shop and uh it was
pretty big coffee trip actually it was
really nice one um but they don't they
would call out your number obviously in
Japanese yeah yeah and uh this person
ordered after me and I I figured that
they were what their number was because
they were right after me and uh yeah
they they look like they're having
nightmare time ordering and then I felt
bad and then the number got called and I
went up to them and I was like oh hey by
the way that's your the shows I'm pretty
sure oh okay thanks but then they they
seemed really confused that I came up to
them and told them but yeah they weren't
going up and getting their stuff and I
was like oh okay whatever yeah yeah
there's other time um
I was checking in it was so bad uh I'll
check into the hotel and it was all
going well and the person next to me I
guess they started speaking in Japanese
to them uh you know and even though my
Japanese isn't like perfect I could like
hear that the way she was saying things
was like not great Japanese like it
didn't sound like natural I guess even
though like I'm not great anyway but
like the pronunciation I guess I don't
know me I'm the last person should be
judging
um she started speaking Japanese then
she started speaking Japanese and then
she just immediately was like oh [__] I
don't know what the [__] happening and
I I it was kind of like I was like I was
like I don't want to help she's trying
so I was just checking in and it started
just getting more painful and more
painful right right I was like do you
need do you need help she's like no I'm
okay I'm like okay thank God I was like
it only took me like 30 minutes to check
in I think it's just taking forever and
it was like oh cause
because I I live in Japan so I don't
have to show my passport when I check in
sometimes I want to see my cards my
residence card for living here sometimes
they don't technically they're not
supposed to ask and they're not supposed
to copy it it's just a whole some hotels
ask for some hotels don't you can be
pushy about it and say don't do it but
then it like it gets even weirder when
you're traveling with people who do need
to show their passports and it was
always like hey we wanted to offer a
great service where we take the bags to
the room they'd be like hey so before we
check in can we see everyone's passports
I'm like oh but passports are in the
bags that you took took yeah yeah and
they were like oh oh well could you
could you like come back later and scan
them right I was like all right just
never did yeah and I was like it's weird
why do they it's like I have I have like
a different problem every time I go into
a hotel where it's like you know usually
other people right they're like oh can
we see your passports or if you live in
Japan can we at least see also do you
cut all your resume yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and it's so awkward every time like
everyone's you know giving like this
happened and so much on journey across
Japan everyone's giving those I do cards
right and then the cloaks just like you
know looks over at me being like Zodi
card [__] and I and it's so awkward me
having to be like yeah so I don't have
one uh I'm Japanese I can see them
pressing X like it's a doubt they're
like you sure about that [__] oh
you knew horns
interaction on the year then like what's
up how does this interaction normally go
oh no I mean for the most part it's
usually I just say oh I'm Japanese in
Japanese and they're like yeah okay I'm
gonna [__] try that yeah I'm gonna
say it see if they stop asking me for my
document yes but then every now and then
when it's like especially in like if
it's like a big city for example with
lots of foreigners they they're kind of
just like what do you mean by that like
what do you mean you're Japanese
research music and I'm like uh so I just
don't I don't have a anxiety you can't I
live here I have yeah well I think I
actually did like I I don't I'm not 100
sure on this but I'm pretty sure even if
you live here that you're like they're
not required to have your ID no but
again I guess how do you like take my
word for it like I guess I don't know I
guess I have to do that I'm like yeah
they're like no you're not Japanese you
clearly don't look at it like this I am
just trust you know I've got chatting
with some people who uh have Zaria cards
and they really don't like I guess
because it's just like the principle
they don't want to show them yeah like
I'm actually half a shirt [__] you yeah
they're like no I'm not sure anymore
they always photocopy it as well yeah
which I don't get why do they photocopy
myself I'm like I don't know I guess
maybe it's for like uh like insurance
reasons maybe I guess but it's like if
you kind of [__] up a room so hard then
it's like well we got your info ready a
little bit you know a little bit
xenophobic to just only get like the
foreign residence I guess it's kind of
weird yeah so they can actually if it's
a police officer
so
did you just say like oh Japanese to it
but like everyone else that would care
but if it's a police officer yeah no no
no police officer yeah they can actually
you obviously yeah but like checking
into a hotel I think that if if you want
to you don't have to prove that you're
but I guess yeah it's hard for them as
well right well then you're a life hack
next time you're at a hotel just be like
in this yeah
Connor coming up to the hotel by the way
actually this is it's weird because like
normally whenever I travel for work in
Japan like we're filming stuff yeah yeah
I don't know if it's I noticed that
um this is such a a expat [__]
problem if you're like booking.com is
still set to a foreign country they'll
they'll 100 ask you for idea when you
get there but yeah because I change
because Chris hasn't done it Chris is
still set to like the UK yeah and I told
him like a million times to change that
[__] because every time we go to a place
they immediately ask for our passports
yeah yeah it's super annoying having to
like do the whole thing uh I set mine to
Japan now so that when I book it
sometimes they ask sometimes they don't
but actually trip no one ever asked me
for it oh that's good and no one ever
tried to photocopy it and I was like oh
this is a nice change of pace that's
what they should do it every holiday
yeah yeah I'm like chill nice sick
awesome coming up with the times I don't
know I just it's just it just saves time
I just don't want to dude it's so
annoying when you when we were cycling
every single day on the cycle we have
this 30 minute [__] check-in where
they want to scan all my documents make
sure I'm like legal and it's like oh my
god dude like let me just check I need a
shower dude I smell like [__] let me in
the room
like I don't know I it's it's weird I
guess especially if like I I don't
actually I wonder if it's something to
do with paying afterwards and paying
um before because all the hotels I paid
before uh and when we did uh when we
traveled uh with Chris or whatever we
always pay after I just also one of the
hotels Chris did forget to pay oh [__]
it was an apple Hotel hey Chris forgot
to pay because she straight up forgot to
pay I just left we were late to the
stream because Chris had to drive back
and go and pay because they called him
up and they're like oh assume I was in
uh money where the [__]
so Chris would drive back and go and pay
because he's just straight up laughed
how many hotels has that man been in how
do you forget this is why when I book it
I just pay right there I'm like this
takes away a giant stress yeah yeah uh
it's just so much easier because you're
gonna pay with the same [__] card
anyway you don't want to pay up front
yeah you don't want to [__] around like
as you're leaving you're probably like
rushing to go somewhere or you know
whatever just like at booking.com more
often not just it gives you like a two
percent discount anyway yeah yeah
anyway yeah
um so you know it's so annoying anyway
so this is such a person living here
problem and even then a more Niche
problem of person living here who
travels around here a lot probably yeah
gig of first world problem
have you ever like you know when uh
whenever you're like living in Australia
or something or somewhere outside of
Japan have you ever like had an
opportunity to help a Japanese tourist
abroad that's like yeah a few times
um but I don't know it's it's weird like
unlike in Japan where there are a lot of
people who come to Japan not knowing the
language whatsoever yeah and are like
clearly struggling yeah a lot of
Japanese people who come to Australia
they're deep they're pretty decent at
English like enough where they can kind
of get around because I feel like for
English mentality yeah I should think
that you'll be accommodated right and I
think like especially with like Japanese
people because for the most part a lot
of Japanese people are like the the
common consensus is like they're very
afraid to like travel overseas because
it's like oh you know Japanese doesn't
really work yeah anywhere else outside
of Japan right so it's like I feel the
people who are actually willing to
travel outside of Japan to different
countries are the ones that are already
probably interested in like learning
English or like learning a different
language anyway yeah so like I've never
had that thing of like I've seen a
clearly Japanese tourist yeah in
Australia struggling because it's like
well you probably know the bare minimum
English to get around anyway yeah so
it's like yeah you'll be all right just
got out I had a moment I was like so
proud of it was just like it made living
here in Japan for like four years worth
it just for this like one moment just
because uh it was actually when I went
to Thailand at last time yeah and uh uh
we were at the airport we just got on
off the plane uh and uh our Sydney was
in the toilet so I was waiting for her
and I could see there there's there was
this like older Japanese couple talking
to one of the Thai staff members uh and
I I you know I just kind of like zoned
in on like their conversation and I
think they were like trying to find kind
of like the right gate to transfer over
to because they were flying to like one
of the islands or something now like you
said they could speak like a little bit
of English yeah but it wasn't great yeah
but also the person that was uh kind of
helping them obviously Thai yeah her
English wasn't great either yeah I saw
this so much it was like a different
tourist trying to speak English to a
Japanese person who also had batting
yeah yeah yeah it was it was like a car
crash every time so it was just like
confusion on both sides there was a Thai
person speaking broken English to a
broken English older Japanese couple who
couldn't also speak English trying to
best interpret that so I was just like
you know what I think this is my moment
I I think I think this is my moment and
so I come over and uh I you know I I ask
to the person I tell the person in Thai
is everything okay I can speak like a
little bit of Japanese and she explains
to me oh you know I'm trying to explain
to them the directions of the gate and
the plane that I can get to and I was
like thank God I can actually my
language skills are good enough to like
translate this and then and then so I
translate them to uh I say what she says
in Japanese and they go
it's like why do you want to yeah yeah
exactly exactly and I was and then they
were like oh why do you speak Japanese
and I was like oh I'm I just literally
flew flew from Japan I live in Japan
right now uh I had a nice pleasant
conversation and I was like yeah you go
here you go there I hope you have a nice
Journey here and I hope you have a nice
day in Thailand and it was just like
that was that was I don't know sometimes
it's the little things of life and I
just I was like beaming I was beaming
all day just because that one
interaction I was like I was like yes
it's so weird because like in Australia
I've had so many instances where it's
like it's that situation but flipped
yeah so it's like I I could be like
walking around in you know somewhere in
Sydney like somewhere where I'm like
clearly know where I'm going maybe I'm a
little bit lost you know maybe it's
because it's like a suburb I've never
been to yeah and I've had people who you
know mistake me for a different
nationality many times right uh I
remember one time I was in I forgot
where I even was but it was a place I'd
never been to before and I was like
looking for a particular I think like
restaurant or something to meet up with
a friend
and I'm like where the [__] is this
place and I'm like looking on my phone I
don't know where it is yeah and this
like dude just he's just like excuse me
and he just comes up to me it's just
like I think he was like Indian or you
know maybe like you know Pakistani
something like that yeah and he just
starts speaking to me in Hindi
yeah he just starts speaking to me in
Hindi and I'm like and I tried to tell
him I was like uh I'm sorry man I don't
know I don't know what you're talking
about yeah and he just and he's like oh
oh you speak English yeah and I'm like
yeah I speak English I don't speak
whatever the [__] you just spoke to me
yeah and he was like trying it's like oh
it looked like yeah it's like I thought
you were like a like an Indian tourist
or something like trying to figure out
where you wanted to go and I'm like dude
that's my fear of like helping who I
think is a Japanese person yeah and they
just speak a completely different
language yeah oh [__] okay I've had that
so many times where I thought they were
Japanese and they were like Korean yeah
yeah and I'm just like oh sorry I
thought I've had that so many times
where I've uh gone to a place thought
they were Thai and uh it turns out
they're Vietnamese organization I
literally when we were when we were oh
no America tool I think we were in like
New Jersey or something it was like our
day off and now you guys have got to get
dinner and I'm like I I [__] miss
Thai food man I just want some Thai food
sure go to the local Thai restaurant
Southeast Asian guy serves me and I'm
like oh my God I'm back home and I start
speaking to him in Thai and he's just
like uh sorry I I don't speak to I I'm
uh I'm Malaysian I'm like God God damn
it man I thought I was home right now I
thought
but I thought it felt great bro it felt
like my third eye was had to open
because this was the first situation I'd
ever been in my life where I had not
used my first language I I had used my I
guess my second language and now my
third language and I'm just like yo is
this the power of a trilingual
validation yeah yeah yeah yeah have I
have I unlocked the trilingual power now
oh my God this it feels incredible yeah
but uh yeah hopefully hopefully that
that kind of like little moments like
that I'm just like oh I should I should
study more Japanese now yeah that's like
reignited my passion for yeah like
hearing stories like that makes me want
to learn a third language but I just
don't know what yeah this isn't it Hindi
to counteract I can't do this it's got
to be handy bro yeah I started speaking
in Hindi I'm like well funny you say
that actually uh well imagine how big
your fan base would get if you knew him
you wouldn't be huge you would quadruple
your viewership right bro it would be
game changing extra one billion fans all
right then and there dude not gonna lie
dude I'm gonna say it I'm [__] sick
of getting the hunger jokes
like seven years oh just you know what I
always thought there was a part of me
that was like it's super endearing it's
you know it's very humbling you know
that I look clearly not Japanese and you
know Japanese people are like you know
it validates that oh my Japanese hasn't
fallen off a cliff you know like
considering that I don't actively study
it as much as I used to because I just
don't have as much time anymore yeah but
like it's it's gone to the point now
where like I was in Harajuku a few days
ago with Aki and we were just doing some
shopping or whatever and I think I got
every single store we stopped at
immediately
to me and it's just like I I know
exactly why they're asking that yeah and
and like I don't blame them for it but
it's this now you've just started this
conversation of well why are you so
nihongo josu right yeah tell me why yeah
it's like it's like so so like how did
you study it did you you know how long
have you lived in Japan yeah there's a
myriad of questions that it can go yeah
yeah yeah and I've just gotten so sick
of just having to do the same [__]
dialogue options over and over it's like
yeah so in my mum's Japanese I lived
here for a while I studied NPC now yeah
it's it's gone but now after all of the
times that I've been in hongo Jose I
figured out the most optimal like
conversation Ender right I just go
thanks
no more that's that's all the info
you're getting because I used to have to
be like yeah my mom's Japanese or you
know like I lived here I studied yeah
yeah now if I just say that's
it they're like oh okay clearly this
person does not want to talk yeah you
you chose the secret option rude
yeah yeah just ends the conversation do
you guys still get it often yeah yeah
how do you guys feel towards it I'm sure
with it yeah well you haven't had it as
much also I'm not Japanese as well for
me it's like a it's almost like an open
invitation to kind of speak Japanese and
practice a little bit yeah I'm kind of
chill with it but obviously you don't
need it
depends if they're nice or not if
they're annoying or no no like granted
like every like especially like store
close and stuff like that who ask it
super nice super nice but you know
they're just trying to like have
conversation right yeah you know they're
like genuinely impressed but it's like
now I'm just kind of like I've done my
shopping yeah I mean it's certain people
when they say it and it starts
conversation I'm like oh God yeah
like mainly taxi drivers taxi drivers
here because they're normally really old
yeah they get like really good
conversations or just like you know I've
never had it in a taxi really yeah ever
I find that Japanese taxi driver is
there either like like really talkative
really talkative or just completely
silent yeah you cannot get a word out of
them I don't know maybe I'm just like
getting really lucky or I don't catch a
Taxis as often as you guys but like I
always get the taxi drivers that are
just two word answers I got in the cab
today with my parents you know it's
always awkward because you know I if
when there's like four of you and you
know some of the taxi drivers they don't
want people to sit in the front it's
just like a preference thing but it's
like hey there's four of us we gotta sit
in the front of course yeah yeah and so
it's like sometimes they they're like oh
I don't move my stuff and some of them
are like bro some of them they got [__]
everywhere and you're like
sending this one to actually dude was
super old definitely like late 80s yeah
90s
um
and dude I sat down on the front seat it
was wet
the [__] I was like oh this is so nasty
sit down dudes dude is so old and he's
like I'll do Japanese again like oh
thanks man he's like oh where are you
from man I go I'm the idiot he's like oh
gentleman country
I was like maybe maybe back in your time
yeah
I was like oh yeah I guess he's like
he's like
[Music]
saying English words just the most
random [__] he's like those are the best
though yeah I I have out recently where
I was just kind of waiting around in a
store I was looking at some clothes yeah
and this like young Japanese guy like
walks up to me and you know just is like
oh this one very popular color
right I love it I love it and it's like
in Japanese I said back and I'm like oh
yeah I bought some clothes from here
before yeah and then the guy was
obviously thrown back and he's like you
know and then he's just like and but
then afterwards in English he was just
like oh you're Japanese very good I love
that and then and then and then he was
like where are you from and I was like
okay if I say yeah if I say Japan things
are just gonna get complicated so I was
like I'm from Australia in the most
Australian accent possible and he
[__] goes and you know when
foreigners think of Australia right lots
of different things kangaroo boomerangs
whatever right the most stereotypical
[__] a Japanese person can feel this
dude legit goes ah woman basketball
[Music]
it's not the first thing I think of when
I think of Australia's running through
my mind yeah I did not think it was good
I was throwing it back being like are we
yeah I guess we're known for women's
basketball yeah and I was like yeah yeah
woman's basketball all right yeah
I did not see that coming the old man in
this Taxi
that's some weird [__] he's saying like
I like beer and the whiskey I was like
okay all right thanks man
that'll be two Yen sorry Nissan yes two
Yen I was like okay
that's steep discounts yeah I'll take it
but dude this man was we got a stoplight
red lights not even kidding yeah man
pulled out the full newspaper at the
stoplight started reading the newspaper
God damn the whole windshield reading
the newspaper I was like oh you're gonna
help hold it you're like you're good
like what do you see the lights what are
you doing
the lights had changed four minutes ago
and we haven't moved sir genuinely he
just whipped it out I couldn't believe
it I've noticed taxi drivers in Japan by
the way
I would not have any Tokyo no I don't
know because I I a lot of taxi drivers
I've like been with they've they've
always had okay they always have of the
clipboards right do you know what I'm
talking about oh yeah yeah
because okay I figured it out okay what
is that well I think they keep track of
like everyone that's got in their taxi
or something even though the meter
already does this yeah yeah I think it's
like they I'm not sure what they're
clocking but a lot of the taxi drivers
if not all of them they you know even
though you're doing you get paid this
amount for the journey all of them are
like employed right by a company most of
them I think I'm again I'm not 100 sure
a lot of them are and so that that's not
their pay what you're paying now yeah
they're your salary so I think they're
like keeping track of something keeping
track of something I don't know yeah I
always thought they were like racially
profiles
secret police every time she's a secret
police officer just tracking your
movements
in case the police come being like did
you see a white male in his 30s getting
your taxis
no because what always confused me is
that I I assume they would keep in track
of like the fair or something but they
never ever do it off after you finish
your journey it's always always it's
always mid light sometimes the lives go
and they're still [__] writing and
their hands are off the uh steering wall
and they just [__] go they're like no
I need to finish this racial profile I'm
gonna sit next time and start writing
stuff too I'm anxious and then I close
the book to death now
if you're sitting in the front seat just
grab just stop playing Tic-Tac-Toe yeah
your move
yeah but no like uh like I guess it was
like the hunger josu is kind of like
most of the time just like conversation
starter do Japanese people find it as
endearing when we just start speaking I
always do I always win Eagle jewels to
do them as well yeah oh really yeah yeah
oh and I've said I do now I've started
doing it everywhere yeah do Japanese
people find it as endearing when we
speak broken ass Japanese be like ah I
think so bearded ah oh dude Japanese
people
they love that [__] even if they don't
it's like I think they just prefer it
right like yeah yeah I think I think in
in a lot of minds of Japanese people
like stereotypically I guess like yeah I
think the the general consensus is oh
you're going to the effort to try and
speak to me in the local language and I
think that in and of itself is worth I
guess like the praise or the respect
right because you know it's so easy to
just be like yeah you know what this
weird Japanese language I'm not gonna
learn it my natural language is better
just deal with it kind of thing right
but it's like I think it's the idea of
like oh you know I can only speak
Japanese yeah and you're participating
in speaking Japanese no matter how
broken it is hey you know what new
Hunger [__] Josie dog let's go
because I think because there's a lot of
people online are always like man it's
so disrespectful to go to a country and
and not know any of the language it's
like well I mean a lot of Japanese
people don't expect you to no that's
like whether you should or shouldn't it
doesn't really matter it's the
expectations that I think a lot of Asian
countries are like okay okay well here's
the thing when you go to like uh when
you when you travel around how much
research do you do you do to a place
before you like travel there I mean
research is in like in in the language
in anything you know
um like very little you know
language-wise I'll probably learn how to
order that's and then yeah yeah I don't
because I normally you know I'll maybe
learn like basic readings like Hello
thank you yeah yeah stuff like that but
yeah I'm not gonna learn like Just
Enough full sentence hopefully not be a
nuisance yeah yeah
um but then obviously when you check
into hotels and stuff you'd like okay
please have hopefully please have
English yeah yeah because because I I
had this when I went to Vietnam because
it's been like quite a while since I had
just traveled to a new country that I
had just never been to before and it was
just like a quick weekend trip so I
didn't actually do that much research uh
after I uh after I got off the plane and
I was like oh [__] uh do they is is
English as common here as it is in
Thailand [__] I don't actually know I
didn't I didn't bother learning any
Vietnamese phrases because I'm just here
for the weekend [__] uh so like it's it
was just like that kind of realization
of just oh I'm that dumb tourist now
[__]
I I am actually that dumb tourist now
right it's it's a feeling that I I guess
like I've forgotten for a while because
most of the time when I travel it's like
[__] America or like other
English-speaking countries you know so I
think like the the mentality I go into
it is like say like you know a couple of
months ago I went to Korea for the first
time right where it's like you know mo
in Korea most people can speak English
yeah at least did you know that
beforehand though or uh I had heard
about it okay but you know they say that
about a lot of countries yeah yeah yeah
true right so you know I went in there
ex you know being like all right well
you know what I'm probably not gonna
bother like you know learning
you know a lot of like extensive phrases
or anything in Korean but I'll just
learn the basics and then when I get
there I'll try and learn as much of it
as I can like I'm much rather in the in
in this head space of like it's better
to even to be that dumb tourist at least
to show that you want to kind of learn
the language and I think that is just as
uh appreciated by the locals then you
already knowing it right so like there
were so many times where if I knew that
like you know the I'd go to a random
food stall in in Seoul and the guy would
be speaking to me in English I would
just be like how do you say this in
Korean yeah and the guy was very happy
to like teach me how to say it and you
know when I would reflect back on it
he'd be like yeah there you go you got
it yeah so I think like just showing no
matter what you know the you know no
matter how it is just showing that you
are interested in it I think is what
will get the locals to be like all right
cool you know what I respect that and I
think the only reason why that doesn't
work as much in in Japan as it does in
say Korea is because a lot of Japanese
people are a little bit afraid of
reserved and reserved to talk to
foreigners and tourists whereas in Korea
they're a lot more open about it yeah
being like yeah you know you're you're a
tourist yeah I see Taurus all the
[__] time well you know I'll teach
you some words yeah yeah did you find
out like when you went on your Euro trip
like this is like pre-pandemic did you
because you went to like a lot of
different countries yeah you know like a
very very short period of time but I
guess you had like a guide right well
yeah we went to like six or yeah six
different European countries all for the
first time but yeah we because it was me
and Aki's first time in Europe so we
were like I'd rather go to a country
where I have like a friend living there
like like show me around so like I had
my local friend with me there but also
you know I did the same thing where like
whenever I would be served something
yeah I would ask the store clerk or
whatever to be like how do you say this
in French or Italian or you know what
whatever country I'm in and I think for
the most part it they seem to appreciate
it right yeah yeah I guess yeah being do
I remember any of them no you remember
for that one trip sometimes sometimes
you just fly somewhere you're like maybe
I'll just you quickly Google so when I
was in Finland I learned so much [__]
finish I couldn't tell you a single
[__] finish phrase right now is when
you're a tourist it's like as long as
you're not being a dick yeah yeah it
doesn't really matter I think I think
there's nothing wrong with being the
dumb tourist I think the problem lies in
being the Arrogant done tourist of like
you're not open-minded enough to like
involve yourself in the culture that's
when you kind of get the stink eye but
if if you're like you can be the dumb
tourist just be like the Curious dumb
Taurus I think it's just looking up
maybe like what the general kind of
etiquette is on certain places before
you turn up is probably just yeah yeah
you can watch a [__] top 10 list of
things to do and don't do yeah like you
know in Japan and every other country on
Earth probably but yeah it just tells
you hey this is this is a cool thing to
do this is definitely not cool thing to
do like I think that's just you know
that helps yeah I look into that for
sure because the last thing I want to do
is be the dumb tourist that also offends
the country I mean you know yeah I think
as long as you're you know polite I
think yeah whatever yeah yeah I mean you
know we dunk on tourists yeah we're done
for tourists a lot even though we a lot
of times we are tourists yeah yeah it's
uh you know ultimately there's nothing
wrong with being a tourist of course
yeah because you [__] have to be yeah
um everyone's a tourist yeah but you
know I think it's just hey if you're
chill who cares okay as an Australian
right so in England I don't know if this
is just uh I don't know if this is just
like a British thing but one thing I've
noticed is you know as a Brit every time
I see like a broad like making a [__]
fool of themselves which I've seen
terrible so many times I'm like
England's got the worst tourist in the
world and then I was like I was talking
to Sydney and she's like no Americans
are the worst tourists in the world and
then I you know I one time I like met a
french guy and he thinks they're the
worst stories in the world as an
Australian do you think you are like the
worst tourist in the world yeah
because it's like it depends on the
location with Australians right because
I think Australians in like say Tokyo or
Osaka uh for the most part pretty all
right yeah but say Australian tourists
at ski resorts
yeah like you know I worked with them
and I can 100 say they're the worst
because like it's it's I think it's like
Australian I think a lot of Australian
tourists because you know for the most
part we're very very Multicultural
country so we're just living in
Australia unless you're living in like
the butt [__] middle of nowhere you're
most likely going to run into different
cultures right whether you like it or
not so I think for the most part
Australians who live in cities are
naturally inclined to understand that
there are cultural differences wherever
you go right not just language
differences but I don't know what it is
about the the atmosphere of a ski resort
in Japan that just makes Australians go
yeah [__] the culture I'm here to rip
the Snow Dogs
yeah kind of like hotels are kind of
like a dorm in a way yeah yeah it feels
like you know a lot of these like ski
lodges they do kind of like uh have more
of like a western feel of like just come
in it's casual you know hang out with
the people in the lounge area oh they're
all Australians as well you guys will
get along fine go you know rip it in the
snow whatever yeah yeah but then they
take that energy to the nearby Village
yeah and the nearby cities and it's just
like I because I remember when I worked
in hakuba I would you know frequently go
into uh like Nagano and like nigata to
do some work and you'll see those exact
same like ski bro Australians in these
cities yeah oh wow
because the the two main ski resorts and
you'd go into the cities and you would
see the the ski Bros there and they're
just some of the most loudest most
obnoxious tourists I've ever met I'm
just like bro we're not in the ski
lodges anymore we're in a city with
hundreds of terrified Japanese people
calm down keep it in the launch yeah I
mean I I guess I just noticed as well
normally when when I make when I meet
like British people in Japan they can
come into Japan most of them all are
pretty chill right all of them shelves
for some reason I I I I every time I see
uh especially English tourists
especially in like southeast Asia in
Thailand I I'm I saw it as a reputation
oh I saw so many in when I went to
Vietnam and every time I heard the
English accent I'm like I do not know
this I I am I am not my man I am Thai
for the rest of this trip actually that
poor taxi driver who thought English
people were Gentlemans
yeah yeah I mean I think there's certain
destinations that yeah let's say uh more
bang for your bark money yeah I think
attract a certain type of British
tourist yeah and probably other European
tourists too but mainly British ones
there like like what's like the main
like I guess party country or Party
location for like Bruce it's like Ibiza
a lot of like the Spanish Islands some
of the Greek Islands because in
Australia that's Bali so when you go to
I've personally never been to Bali
before but I've heard stories of just
like the most obnoxious Australians in
Bali just like [__] trying to make it
like
an extremely cheap transport
a cheap accommodation and with like the
party atmosphere yeah extremely cheap
alcohol yeah yeah it's just like I guess
like Vietnam and Thailand that are
pretty cheap yeah and drinking oh I saw
I saw so many people from Essex in
Vietnam
there was this one girl who was uh
clearly from Essex
um like having having an argument with
like one of like the Vietnamese
bartenders like over like the price of
this beer or something which the price
of this beer was about one dollar and
she was like no no no like I I got two
for one two for one and she was like
shouting at this waiter and then I I I
don't know I was like standing up like
five minutes and the waiter just comes
up to me and just goes I [__] hate
English girls and I was just like I was
just like
I had that in uh I had that in Japan I
was I was in an Izakaya and this like
group of like four young Australians
like walk in yeah
um and I could immediately hear from
their accents not from the city yeah
yeah so they just like sit down they're
so [__] loud even though we're in an
izakai with lots of people I can hear
them like clearly like they're sitting
next to me and I remember remember this
[__] like the waiter comes over you
know ask for whatever they're ordering
drinks and then they're ordering food
and this [__] girl just like goes oh
so the uh the fried chicken
um is it free rage
[Music]
and I'm just sitting there like
bro you're in you're in a [__]
Kingdom
why are you expecting fine dining in a
[__] dirt cheap Izakaya and I just
started laughing I'm like huh to the
waiter in like the most Aussie accident
clearly this guy doesn't understand
right he's just like oh I'm sorry I
think I've even explained you explain it
perfect Japanese you'd be like the [__]
are you talking yeah so what is that
what does that mean what are you [__]
talking about
GMOs and she was just like and she just
it kept going on and on and on being
like if it's not free range I don't
really want to eat it
and I'm like
just like just don't even bother just go
to go to a fancy I need to know if this
eel died peacefully yeah or if it died
by a hands of a man like you're one
you're one step away from being like Oh
so um is is this meal vegan or uh you
know just [__] oh my God I'm like do
okay I get that you have like you know
you might have like dietary issues like
you know if you want to know like oh
does this have peanuts because I have a
peanut allergy or something like so
you're in the cheapest Izakaya yeah in
the middle of Tokyo yeah do not expect
free-range chicken man's probably
getting paid like five dollars he's not
getting paid enough and I felt so bad
because the guy had to go back and like
get like uh clearly like a staff
understood a little bit more English
yeah and just like this argument just
it's same it seemed like it went off for
ages and it's just like this manager's
trying to tell them being like okay so
uh not gonna lie we don't know if it's
free-range chicken but we can guarantee
it's good it's tasty probably for Frozen
it's 400 Yen I don't know what you're
complaining about and this girl just
kept going on and on and I'm just like
dude come on man like yeah why why are
you doing this so yeah Australian
tourists
one thing one thing I'll say about
American tourists The Stereotype is that
American tourists are the loudest
tourists yeah and I don't know if that's
necessarily true but for some reason
America like every time I see an
American Tourist abroad whatever country
it's in for some reason they always have
the most recognizable voice in any
establishment have you noticed this I
don't know why every American I've seen
in Japan has been super polite yeah no
they have yeah yeah
it's very easy to hear them out yeah
yeah for some reason it could be like
the loudest like bar you've ever been to
and you'll just hear that one American
accent that will pierce through
everything being said this cocktail's
[__] delicious
I don't know if it's because like we
just consume so much American Media yeah
but it's an instantly recognizable kind
of
we hear so much American accents that
when we hear in real life we're like oh
I can immediately hear that yeah I don't
know I I can't put my hand on do you
have that like level of I don't know if
you guys have it for like for British
tourists but like do you have that like
split moment where you hear that British
accent you just like like
kinfolks I have that with Australia yeah
yeah most definitely most definitely
except if it's in Southeast Asian in
which case it's probably I should avoid
them they hate my man's I'm tired for
the day I only speak Thai you don't see
a lot of British people in Japan though
it's kind of right yeah you don't all
Americans yeah which is why which is why
everybody I've met here has been pretty
cool so far pretty chill you have to
like Japan to to want to go here yeah as
a British tourist yeah it's literally
the other side of the world it's like
it's like a 20-hour flight That's True
14-hour Flight like it's it's long
that's how I feel about Australians in
Europe yeah
all right you must really like Europe if
you're gonna sit on a plane for 22 hours
all right let's think about Europe is if
you don't like one of the countries
you're like right I guess I'll take the
20 minute ride cab ride to the next one
that's true yeah yeah oh you didn't like
Liechtenstein well you lucky for you
you're a five minute walk away from
anywhere else just across the road yeah
you'll literally get to go like wherever
you want to go oh my God but that was
our tourist experience from our home
countries I'm I'm curious about toys
experience from your own country uh do
you have the worst the worst tourist in
the world please let us free range are
your chickens free range if so because
because I'm curious because like I yeah
talking to uh told you one of the one of
my French mates he said we have the
worst tourist in the world and I'm like
how can you say that when you're
neighbors to England I thought you I
thought we like just hated each other
fix the location right depends on which
country you're in sure for the biggest
tourists right that's true yeah
hopefully you also learned some tourism
life hacks for Japan as well feel free
to use them on your next visit but uh
hey look at all these patrons oh look at
all these people roughly they're not
annoying Taurus
you guys are on patreon you guys know
everything about Japan yeah they're
[__] 190 goddamn episodes hell yeah
yeah exactly yeah because this is the
best place to learn about it you already
know way too much about Japan but uh Hey
if you like to support the show go over
to our patreon patreon.com trash days
also follow us on Twitter send us memes
on the subreddit and if you hate her
face listen to us on Spotify and we'll
see you all next week bye
foreign
[Music]